Welcome back. So, our favorite defendant, Destiny, aka Steven
Bonnel, was recently on stream, predictably dissecting the latest
court filings in the Pixie case. And predictably, he got a whole
lot wrong mixed with his usual charming blend of bluster and
deflection. Let's break down some of the low lightss, especially
now that we have even more context from recent court documents.
All sources can be found on the Court Listener website in the
description when you hear a document or page number referenced.
Destiny lies about his court case on a nearly daily basis, and
I will not have time to grab each document to site myself, but
all sources can be found in the link provided. Let's get started.
Plaintiff Jane Doe's reply in support of motion for protective
order governing public commentary
by trial participants.
Oh, they want to do a gag order on me, so I'm not allowed to
talk about it,
which is
I will write a man. This will be my final manifesto. I will do
a full write up on this entire thing from start to finish cuz
nobody will cover this um unless I write it all up cleanly just
in terms of like all the unhinged crazy depraved behavior that
the other side has done
uh in the course of this whole case.
comes now plaintiff Jane Doe by and through undersigned counsel
and hereby submits her reply in support of her motion for protective
order governing public commentary by trial participants
and respectfully states as follows.
Defendant's opposition to plaintiff's motion grossly mischaracterizes
the nature uh mischaracterizes the nature of the relief sought,
the applicable legal standards and the relevant facts. Plaintiff
does not seek to muzzle the defendant, nor does she seek to prevent
him from defending himself in court.
Yeah, no, Charlmes.
Rather, plaintiff seeks a narrowly tailored protective order
that applies equally to all trial participants and is only intended
to curb the ongoing harassment, intimidation, and misrepresentation
that threatens the integrity of these proceedings and deter witness
participation. C. Proposed protective order, blah blah blah.
Okay.
The record is clear. Multiple potential witnesses have withdrawn
their willingness to testify due to fear of retaliation and doxing
by defendant and his followers. There's never been any evidence
of this submitted ever. But
Defendant has made explicit threats of violence against plaintiffs
witnesses. Again, Queen Andistle are not witnesses in this case,
so it has nothing to do with that at all. But we can I guess
you could just lie over and over and over and over and over and
over and over again in every single motion I guess you file.
But okay,
you frame this protective order governing public commentary ECF499
as a personal attack, a gag order specifically to muzzle you.
But let's read what plaintiff's council actually filed, shall
we? Fact check from ECF 104. Plaintiff's reply in support of
motion for protective order. Contrary to defendants's framing,
the proposed protective order is not an asymmetric gag order.
It explicitly applies to all trial participants, including plaintiff,
and prohibits only that public commentary, which disparages,
threatens or intimidates parties, council or witnesses, discloses
sealed identities or confidential attorney communications, misrepresents
legal filings or court orders, discloses sensitive personal allegations
or private details of the parties or witnesses. So, Mr. Bonnel,
it applies to everyone, including Jane Doe.
It's not about stopping you from discussing the case. It's about
stopping everyone from turning this into a circus of harassment
and misinformation that could prejudice the trial. Something
plaintiff argues you've been a ring leader in. You claim 1039
this isn't narrowly tailored and is a 100% gag order. Really?
So you're saying your defense requires you to disparage, threat,
and docks or misrepresent court filings? That's quite the admission.
The plaintiff argues ECF 104. This is about protecting vulnerable
witnesses from intimidation and ensuring that testimony may proceed
free from fear or retaliation, citing your alleged threats and
doxing. Maybe if you stuck to facts instead of vitrial, this
wouldn't even be on the table.
I went through all of the declarations and I think I only saw
one person
um who said something, but it wasn't even
This is so
dude. you. She's just She's still running with the with this
is just hearsay. This I'm sorry. This is double
Make them submit an affidavit or declaration saying it. You can't
just speak for everybody. That's not how this works, little bro.
You can't just say like somebody else said this. You have to
they need to sign that. They need to attest to that under oath.
They have to sign a thing saying that I promise this is my sworn
and truth statement because maybe you're misinterpreting things
or maybe they say they wouldn't say that. You I don't know why
they keep doing this. I know why. It's cuz they're It's cuz it's
malicious is the actual answer. But never been any evidence submitted
ever. Mr. Bonel, are you reading the same filings we are or just
the ones that fit your narrative? Plaintiff's council has repeatedly
stated that witnesses have expressed fear.
They filed declarations from ABMC, witness A, and witness B under
seal ECF 492494495
precisely because these witnesses requested anonymity due to
fear of retaliation. a fear plaintiff directly attributes to
your conduct ECF 104 page 2 ECF98
page three.
You dismiss Pixie's own declaration ECF841
as you reference around 2024 about what these witnesses told
her as double hearsay. But plaintiff's team argues ECF 105 page
4 that hearsay is permissible in preliminary injunction proceedings
especially when supporting declarations already presented.
You also conveniently ignore the part where plaintiff's council
says ECF 104 page 5 plaintiff's declaration and supporting evidence
show that she specifically identified four potential witnesses
that have communicated their reluctance to participate due to
their fear of defendants doxing and vicious attacks. Make videos
about you like this is what they this is like the pattern. It
is soing irritating. That's why people like and if I could I
would put their balls in a vice and crush them and then slice
them off and then feed them to them and then slice their and
kill them. Okay, them because they're amplifying all this and
they're knowingly playing a part of it. They know what's going
on, but like moreover, the three witnesses who have agreed to
testify and provided declarations would only do so under seal
due to their fear of defendants retaliation.
So to say there's never been any evidence is, to put it mildly,
a gross misrepresentation of what's been filed and argued. They're
arguing your actions are the reason evidence gathering is hindered.
ECF 104, page 5.
defendant has made explicit threats of violence against plaintiff's
witnesses.
Again, Queenman and Justistical are not witnesses in this case.
So, it has nothing to do with that at all. But we can I guess
you can just lie over and over and over and over and over and
over and over again in every single motion I guess you file.
But okay, as detailed in plaintiff's motion and supporting declaration,
defendant has publicly threatened to kill potential witnesses.
I'd kill them if I could. I want someone to kill named witnesses.
Again, just and are not witnesses in this case, but as long as
Kiwi Farms continues to post it, I guess that's they'll continue
to copy paste it. Um, I don't again I don't know how long you
can just lie about something over and over and over and over
and over and over and over again. Maybe maybe this will just
be the lie that they carry if they get there all the way to trial.
Maybe. Who knows? One, this interview was done a long time ago.
Two, this isn't even published on my channel. Three, these people
are not parties to this case. These people are not witnesses.
They have nothing to do with any of this and none of my commentary
about them here has anything to do with this case.
So, it's like it's so stupid.
This commentary is not merely uncomfortable or critical as defendant
absurdly claims,
but rather violent and extremely prejuditial. This commentary
undeniably deters witness cooperation and undermines the fair
ministry of justice. Both of these people, Queman and have talked
about me incessantly
for months after. Clearly, they're not deterred and clearly they're
not afraid. So, like what are we even talking about
You keep hammering this point that JSDLK and Queen Man aren't
formally listed witnesses in this specific case right now. And
plaintiff's council might even concede that for the sake of argument.
The argument isn't just that you threaten formally listed witnesses.
It's that your alleged violent rhetoric against people who speak
out against you or support the plaintiff creates a chilling effect
that deters potential witnesses or anyone from coming forward.
Plaintiff argues ECF 104 page 5. This commentary, your alleged
threats against JSDLK and Quean is not merely uncomfortable or
critical, but rather violent and extremely prejuditial. This
commentary undeniably deters witness cooperation and undermines
the fair administration of justice.
So whether they are currently witnesses or not is almost a red
herring. Plaintiff is arguing your alleged pattern of behavior
and violent statements create an atmosphere of fear making anyone
scared to get involved thus prejudicing her ability to build
her case. It's about the environment you allegedly create.
disclosed the sealed identity of
Her name was literally posted on her gifts and go when she initially
um
published it. But also this was it was I her name was used the
same day she filed for a protective order. After that I haven't
done it at all and I've removed it when they've asked. But I
like how she keeps saying this over and over
disclosed plaintiff's legal name in violation of the court's
anonymity order. Again, this happened before the protective order
came out. Since then, not disclosed the person's name. Um, and
clearly the plaintiff didn't really care because they withheld
that like the name was in the video for months so that they could
have it in a motion, you know, 6 months into the case, I guess.
But,
Published confidential meet and confer
published confidential I don't even know if these communicial
but okay and engaged in a pattern of disparagement and ridicule
directed at plaintiff her witnesses and prospective witnesses
and plaintiff's counsel
I mean plaintiff has done the same to me I mean like you when
you've made a public substack
that is unhinged
and contains like a ton of lies in it and then you cry that I
think that you're a crazy person like this. It's just so ridiculous,
but whatever. Um,
you're playing fast and loose with timelines and
Pixie was granted permission to proceed under a pseudonym by
court order on February 20, 2025, ECF7, but the initial motion
ECF5 would be around then. Plaintiff alleges ECF 104, page 4,
that you disclosed plaintiff's legal name in violation of the
court's anonymity
Your defense is that this happened before the protective order
came out. If the order was issued, say Feb 20th, and your video
disclosing her name was after that date, then your timeline is
wrong. If it was before Feb 20th, then the act of keeping it
up after the order was in place could still be seen as a continuing
violation as argued by
You also claim clearly the plaintiff didn't really care because
they withheld that like the name was in the video for months
so that they could have it in a motion. This is pure speculation
about her motives and deflects from your actions. She's now clearly
stating it's a violation.
And as for her name was literally posted on her gift and go,
"If true, that might be a point your lawyers can make, but it
doesn't absolve you of violating a court order if that's what
happened." Plaintiff's team ECF99 footnote 2 also pushes back
stating you briefly mentioned her first name in a video before
the Pixie order, but then you were the one who flagged the timestamp,
amplifying the very disclosure.
And then the second meme is
Oh, I think we filed I think we filed to have the one the Abby
MC completely tossed because it was just for I don't I don't
even re it was a ridiculous
uh submission. But is that their proposal for a gag order? Basically,
yes. They call it a protective order, but that's basically what
it was.
Plaintiff Jane Doe's reply in support of motion to file redacted
evidence in support of the declaration of ABMC and for leave
to file under seal. So, first of all, when they filed ABMC's
declaration, they should have attached the evidence to it. I
don't know why they didn't. They probably didn't even have it
at the time because they don't give a if any of the people talking
to them or even making real uh allegations against me or not,
which is evidenced by the fact that they were relying on DMs
from people whose identities they hadn't even ascertained before
filing the complaint and then graveling in front of the judge
for a temporary restraining order two months after filing the
case and then trying to blame their cancer treatments on their
late filings. just so ridiculous. Don't take the Don't take the
case. If you can't balance chemo and motions at the same time,
why you why you like I don't even know if you're competent to
practice at that point, but whatever. By the way, Destiny sends
me tapes all the time and he thinks I don't know the girls in
them, but I have videos of him
Cherry and Pixie like Limo. He just sent me another one. Haven't
opened it. Let's see who he's this time. He should be more careful.
basically lio this is the totality of the evidence that this
person has that I've ever sent them anything which I haven't
because another thing they
in the hearing um that they said very clearly I think on two
different occasions was um this person never gave them any evidence
whatsoever that I actually sent her anything there was no evidence
of that ever submitted ever they admitted that they hadn't seen
evidence of it at all
in case you're not aware this is the one thing right here. This
is the entire case is built on this one message. Attempt to strike
the evidence corroborating the declaration of MMC reeks of desperation.
See defendants opposition. For months, the defendant has been
gloating on his platforms to his hundreds of thousands of followers
that despite his heinous acts, he will not be held accountable
because he allegedly shared the video prior to the effective
date of Cardi. No, I have not said that I think anything wrong
happened or that anything was done, you know, non-consensually,
whatever. Uh, that's a that would be an argument that we could
have uh if they had subject matter jurisdiction. But the first
argument we're going with is, of course, is you're trying a case
that you don't even have the authority to file in federal court.
You chose to file in federal court. You spend a lot of time trying
to discredit the AbbeyMC declaration and the text message screenshot
ECF861
that Pixie claims shows you shared the video after Cardi became
effective.
Pixie's team argues this Abbey MC evidence does establish subject
matter jurisdiction by showing a postcardi disclosure ECF 105
page 2. They also argue for jurisdiction under an ongoing distribution
doctrine ECF 105 footnote 1 ECF94
page 35 by you making the content continuously accessible via
links.
You claim this person never gave them any evidence whatsoever
that I actually sent her anything331.
But Pixie submitted ABMC's sworn declaration ECF492
and the corroborating text message ECF861.
Pixie's lawyers argue that the text dated NAV 3 2023 directly
corroborates ABMC's claim you sent her the video of Pixie ECF
105 page 4 and that you didn't even meet Abby MC until 2023 well
after Cardi was law ECF94
page 5.
You mock the idea that the date of the text NAV 3 2023 corroborates
the transmission
Pixie's argument is that ABMC couldn't have known about the video
to text her friend about it on NAV 3 2023 if you hadn't sent
it to her before that date. Especially since the mass public
leak was Nav 29 2024 ECF94
page 5.
You also attack the evidence as new and untimely.
Pixie Council responds ECF 105 page 23 that ABMC's declaration
May 2nd referenced the text chat and the screenshot was submitted
June 2nd before the June 3rd hearing and in response to your
objections that ABMC provided no supporting exhibits.
Your claim that your only defense is lack of subject matter jurisdiction.
1031 is something Pixie's council directly calls a lie in their
filings. ECF 105 page 2. And you yourself admit you can't read
the sealed hearing transcript where this was discussed.
They sent me what? They they sent the versions that they sent
me were redacted. So I don't even know personally who these what
the
seriously these are I have the same
so there are people who are afraid of me and I don't even know
who Okay based absolutely based
oh this image is redacted so I don't know that one this is redacted
I don't know that one oh and that message is redact cool all
right cool that's good
based
So, I don't know. I have no further information. I wouldn't be
able to tell you guys publicly. It'd be nice to know for my own
case. Um, so I could like defend myself, but that's cool. That's
fine. I don't have to know any of it, I
Like, how does this even make sense? If you file it under seal,
I still get access to the name. Do you think I'm willing to have
these people like physically
attacked,
but if you file it under seal, I won't do that?
You seem confused about how sealed documents often work or you're
deliberately misrepresenting it to your
When documents are filed under seal, it typically means they
are shielded from the public. It does not automatically mean
the opposing party's lawyers don't get to see them. In fact,
your own lawyer, Mr. Breler argued voseiferously ECF-72 that
he should get unredacted copies. The judge granted plaintiff's
motion to seal from the public ECF75.
It's standard practice for council to then get access often under
a protective order.
Plaintiff's council Joan Peters even stated in an email 723 part
of your own filing. Defendant has no right to receive the unredacted
documents at this time, i.e. before a court ruling and protective
measures. and Carlos Garcia Perez stated ECF723.
If the court grants the motion to seal, you will know their identities.
So, your lawyers likely do or will know. Your insinuation that
you personally not knowing cripples your defense or that sealing
means your lawyers don't know is misleading. It's about protecting
witnesses from public harassment which plaintiff argues you're
prone to inciting. Your odd statement 2438 about how you wouldn't
attack them if it's sealed but might otherwise is well telling.
and to listen to and encourage with financial renumeration
is abuse of the plaintiff, her witnesses, and her
They keep bringing this up over and over and over again, despite
the fact that I've lost money on this. And they know that, too,
because that was also part of our hearing, which is probably
another reason why they want to keep it sealed.
Defendants should certainly not object to plaintiff's GoFundMe
page. It's a give andgo page. Got him. since he has been profiting
immensely from this case by streaming on a regular basis about
it. Uh my lawyer's fees are up to about $200,000 so far. I have
not made that much money. Um talking about this case, uh not
to mention uh canceled shows, reputational harm that will likely
never go away. Um and everything else involved in this. But
that's cute to say this over and over again. They really really
really like to run with this argument.
This profit revenue is evidenced by the number of views on his
videos about the case and the number of comments and questions.
For example, streamers such as defendant receive revenue from
their YouTube channels based on memberships, AdSense revenue.
Streamer gets paid based on number of users viewing ads and super
chats. The user pays to have his or her message highlighted in
the live chat during a stream. The more money is paid, the more
likely the stream will read the message aloud or respond to the
question. Plaintiff's council repeatedly claims you're profiting
immensely from this case through your streams. ECF 104, page
9, footnote 4.
You state your legal fees are around $200,000
and you haven't made that much, plus reputational harm and cancelled
shows.
This is a classic, he said, she said on finances. However, plaintiffs
point ECF-1004
is that your choice to repeatedly stream about the case, often
with what they call distorted and threatening harassing and false
commentary is what draws views and potential revenue and also
what necessitates their request for a protective order on public
commentary. They see it as you monetizing the harassment they
are trying to stop.
So, there you have it. Mr. Bonnel's commentary on the recent
filings is, as usual, a masterclass in spin, omission, and sometimes
outright misstatement of what the legal documents actually say
and what the core legal arguments are. He focuses on strawman
twists timelines and feigns ignorance on procedural matters.
The court will of course be looking at the actual filings and
evidence, not the YouTube commentary. We'll continue to watch
how this